welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and squid game is netflix's most
popular series ever perhaps because we
all know how it feels to lose in this
school yard of life lambs to the
slaughter of powerful forces bent on
controlling us oh god the squid is
netflix the squid
i have loved re-watching this show and
picking up more hidden details like that
squid game icon as a robot's hairpin
such a good easter egg oh yeah i'm so
good but the big unanswered question
that still nags me is the game itself
like i know ilhan created it to restage
the children's games that he played as a
boy and i know all the cool subtle clues
foreshadowing this big reveal but
practically why does this game exist in
this world who are those cartoonish vips
who observe it and as a game that has
kidnapped and killed hundreds of people
every year for decades how do they keep
getting away with it well upon spotting
some new details i've discovered the
dark truth behind the already dark squid
game capitalism i'm kidding well not
really the series critiques of
capitalism are no secret but the reason
why the squid game exists in the world
of the series is that the government
allows it to wants it to and needs it
too squid game draws influence from two
of my favorite films bong joon ho's 2013
film snow piercer and kinji fukusaku's
2000 film battle royale spoilers for
both ahead snow piercer is set in a
post-apocalyptic world in which
survivors all live aboard a strict class
system upon a train chris evans leads a
proletariat revolt to the engine room
where he realizes that the supposed
revolution was actually rigged between
the top and the bottom of society in
order to maintain a cyclical balance in
battle royale the japanese government
straps bomb collars on juvenile
delinquents and forces them into an
island deathmatch you may remember this
premise from its american knockoff the
hunger games oh excuse me it's different
whine all the katnisses who write hunger
games harry potter and literally nothing
else but in snow piercer and battle
royale the violence is orchestrated by
the ruling elites as safety valves for
dystopian societies critiques of how
capitalist leaders turn lower classes
against each other in grotesque combat
to control the hungry masses and this is
also true for squid game players are
recruited from the poor in destitute
debtors gamblers criminals and forced
into gladiator combat but this arena
exists on a secret island operated by
guards sworn to secrecy masked and
numbered forced into obedience a whole
charade designed to sound so far-fetched
that the police won't believe it
[Music]
goes through the archives the game has
been going on for as far back as 1998
meaning that for over two decades
hundreds of people have gone missing
every year many of whom likely returned
to the mainland after their own
cancellation votes and probably would
have given similar reports to police and
still no investigation was pursued now
the front man implies police
incompetence was behind us
we have at least one capable
investigator working for the cops and
with so many outstanding debts left
behind by these losing players there's
gonna be quite a few people eager to
know their whereabouts and ask questions
that probably would uncover this
conspiracy now we never see junhoe's
body so he probably survived right and
it seemed like some of his texts were
going through to his police chief so one
way or another his evidence should have
made it to the police yet one year later
the game continues with another round of
recruiting so what happened well
remember john hoe's phone call
yes right before the call cuts off his
chief asks him what did you do almost
like an accusation like he didn't want
his detective looking into whatever he
was looking into so i believe the
government authorities in the world of
squid game are fully aware of the game
and have instructed police investigators
to turn a blind eye to it yes players
squid game is actually state-sanctioned
illnom with all of his wealth had more
than enough political influence to form
an agreement with the government for
legal immunity in exchange for rounding
up the low-life criminals and debtors
and then paying off their debts to
society when they lose kind of like how
they were prepared to pay off the
families
proposal was to help society maintain
its image of economic prosperity by
secretly exterminating a handful of
bottom feeders annually for his
amusement now i'm not a skincare
aficionado but i do prefer my face to
not look like i've been lost in the
woods for two weeks i want to take care
of the old money maker and the fine
folks at geology hooked me up with some
skincare products that i have been
loving geology is a six time
award-winning men's skincare company
that creates simple effective
personalized skincare products for men
you just take a 30 second quiz and with
a few clicks tell them about your skin
and their team of dermatologists designs
a regimen just for you that ships
directly to your door it's great for
individuals with sensitive skin or acne
or dark eye circles or wrinkles they
send you a 30-day trial set that's easy
to incorporate into your routine whether
you're new to skincare or a seasoned
expert here's what they sent me
in the box we got some everyday wash
that you use to wash your face every day
and then a bit of vital morning face
cream that is vital in the morning and
then repairing night cream oh don't
forget some nourishing eye cream like
even when i've been on the go and have
been able to use all of these every
single day just putting on an everyday
face watch it's made like a world of
difference like my skin just feels
healthier and less like the skin of a
separate demon that's trying to slowly
kill me my skin works for me now also
geology has great customer service and
over 4 000 five-star customer reviews
with an average customer rating of 4.8
out of five that's pretty great people
will notice the results and you will
love the easy routine so head to
geology.com and take their free skincare
quiz and right now you can save 70 off
your 30-day trial when you use the code
rockstars70 or just click the link below
that's geology.com promo code
rockstars70 to save 70 off your 30-day
trial now illnom wanted to spend his
dying months playing the game but then
he met gyun and in him found a possible
successor that he could rig the game to
allow to win kind of like the snow
piercer conductor offering a deal with
the proletariat hero this number one
sets up the bottom player to take it
over but when his chosen successor
refuses to spend his winnings and keep
that capitalist train chugging along
illnom engages him for one final game
the bet over whether or not someone will
help the dying homeless man outside a
game that he again rigs for guillen to
win with that police car pulling up to
the homeless man a little late recalling
the front man's line about korean police
being slow to act implying illness might
have arranged the cops to pull up at
this exact moment the moment the clock
struck the hour all to empower geon to
finally transition into a well-groomed
yuppie with hair the color of his
oppressors and when gyan calls the front
man in the final scene he knows that
guillain is about to board a plane it's
just one final example of the squid
game's pervasive access into the
country's surveillance network this goes
all the way to the top i don't want to
frighten you but not just korea the
reason the squid game can continue after
illnom's death are its wealthy
benefactors the vips continuing it and
we don't learn much about them but they
do wear the masks of a lion tiger bull
bird bear and deer also they're idiots
they'll let no fury like a woman scorn
another student of the bard i had no
idea actually it's not shakespeare it's
congrate william conway i like you
better when you don't talk illness first
invented the game with his wealthy
clients but that probably wasn't these
dopes who likely weren't around in the
90s and now illness having to suffer
through this generation of a-holes might
have been part of what drove him to join
the game instead he'd rather fall to his
death and party with these morons now
the chatty lion and bull strike me as
wall street or silicon valley bros while
the tiger that's the vip junho unmasks
and forces to confess may actually be an
american politician with the most to
lose from such a video getting out and
then the deer speaks mandarin
that sounds so romantic what's it mean
good rain knows the best time to fall
tofu
yeah doofu is a famous chinese poet now
you could see the vips as intentionally
dultish bourgeois archetypes with animal
masks to represent their inhumanity and
savage impulses through contrast the
human empathy were meant to feel toward
the players some have also described the
vips as stand-ins for the netflix
viewing audience but i think the vip's
end goal in keeping the game going has
got to be capitalistic and i think there
are business and political leaders from
the united states and china looking to
expand the squid game experiment to
their home countries and exploit their
own impoverished lower classes not
unlike the way western media has
colonized concepts like battle royale
for their derivative americanized hunger
games i actually wonder if guy young's
stepdad's new job in the united states
was to assist that transition the
connection that led to gion initially
being targeted for recruitment and that
the front man taunted gion to get on the
plane so that he wouldn't get on the
plane to visit gyeong in the u.s and
uncover this globalization plan now i
don't have evidence for that part of it
but i just want to see future seasons of
this show adapt the game for different
countries because capitalism is an evil
without borders comrades new rockstars
breaks down the details you missed with
in-depth analyses of everything you love
so subscribe for more content like this
and support us by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you